Democrats run strong in Pennsylvania's
18th congressional district students
prepare to walk out all day to protest
gun violence and President Trump says
some stuff about a space force or
something I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
so today I am interested in talking
about what's happening with this student
walkout rather than awkwardly staring at
the camera for weird periods of time I'm
actually going to talk about what's
going man sometimes you just off but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at Legal Zoom LegalZoom is
marking National Small Business Month
and whether you're just starting out or
you already have a business there's a
lot you can take advantage of right now
so I've known about Legal Zoom for
literally years it was one of the ways
that I would file documents yeah do
wills and trusts from the time when I
was a younger human but now Legal Zoom
has actually expanded its business
offerings go to legalzoom.com slash
startup during March and you can
download your free business startup kit
you get a ton of great information you
can find out how to maximize your
business deductibles under the new tax
laws plus you'll get great discounts or
could include special deals from Legal
Zoom along with offers from their
service partners so you can save a bunch
of money financing marketing and
operating your business Legal Zoom is
not in fact a law firm but they do know
that you need to tap into the right
resources to run a successful business
and that's why they have their business
startup kid they even have people who
are actually available to answer your
questions as well so it's not just a
list of forums you also have people who
you can consult with go to legalzoom.com
slash startup and download your free
business startup kit tonight we have a
start up here at daily wire Legal Zoom
is invaluable for other people who are
trying to do what we have done they make
it a lot cheaper it means you don't have
to work through these really expensive
law firms spend five hundred bucks an
hour just to get a contract on
legalzoom.com slash startup there is no
obligation just free business resources
and the offer is only available in March
so if you're listening after that you
can still enjoy special savings by using
code Bend when you check out at
legalzoom.com that's legalzoom.com where
life meets legal again use that special
code ban when you check out and you
enjoy special savings and it's only
available in March so we're already
nearing the middle of the month so check
it out there it's legalzoom.com and use
that promo code Ben again these folks I
mean there's a reason they've been top
in the business for for literally more
than a decade at this point check it out
Legal Zoom calm and use promo clear Ben
alright so a couple of big news stories
out the gate today so we will get to
what happened in Pennsylvania's 18th
congressional district last night
because that actually I have a lot of
notes on that but we begin today but
this massive walkout that's happening at
supposedly 2,500 schools all over
America where a bunch of kids
astroturfed by pee
who organized the women's March have
decided to walk out of school for 17
minutes to honor the victims at Parkman
it's rather the Parkland school shooting
the victims in Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in parkland Florida and of
course what this really is is not a call
for an agenda right it's not actually a
agenda driven march rebel you actually
don't know what they want and if you
read what the women's March say they are
marching for nobody agrees with their
actual agenda I'll get to their actual
agenda in a second what it really is
about is about having a lot of pictures
of a lot of young people standing around
and saying that they hate gun violence
so that a bunch of leftist politicians
can claim they are standing with the
children in pushing for vast gun
confiscation regimes that's what this is
all about and that's essentially what
the New York Times admits in their
editorial today they say the children
should lead us which we wish I say fine
then what the children take over your
editorial board they can't do a worse
job than you have fine you just let the
kids run all your op eds and they can
decide whether they want to run op eds
on whether homework is necessary or not
it's really funny all the adults at the
New York Times we're all in their 50s
there they always talked about how
wonderful ingenious these seventeen year
olds are but I don't see them giving up
their jobs anytime soon to high school
juniors who are attending Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school but here's
what they write in their in their
editorial they say adults are supposed
to take care of children not only keep
them safe but make them feel safe weird
I don't hear this from from the New York
Times on issues like abortion that
adults are supposed to take care of
children I don't hear about them with
regard to single motherhood that line
seems to go out the window but now of
course the adults are supposed to take
care of children according to the New
York Times not by defending kids with
guns but by letting kids decide policy
which is a weird way of protecting them
they say schools are essentially an
extension of the home in that sense
providing sanctuaries of learning of
nurturing and care but after years of
attacks by people with weapons of war
students cannot feel safe and are
demanding that adults end years of
complacent and act okay first of all it
is the these school shootings are
actually on the decline not on the
uptick statistically speaking and your
chances of being killed in a school
shooting are significantly worse than
your chances of being killed in
virtually any other sort of accidents in
the United States and these are acts of
terror really say they're not asking for
their schools to become armed Garrison's
well some would like for there to be
more armed guards you say rather they
want those weapons to be brought under
control I like how the New York Times
has a direct link into the minds of all
young people it's amazing it's like
Russo's general will they just look at
young people they magically know that
all of Chuck Schumer's proposals on guns
I have embedded themselves in the minds
of young folks but what is this smack of
its max in the New York Times basically
taking a child putting the child out
front and saying this child demands that
you do what I say you do are you going
to say no to this very cute child it's
like the Pinky and the brain episode
where they decide to take over the world
by becoming small children with big
puppy eyes rather the way to actually
become leaders is to show something
really cute well that's what the New
York Times is basically doing here
they say at Stoneman Douglas junior
Florence Garrett said at the Florida
State Capitol late last month you adults
have failed us by not creating a safer
place for your children to go to school
so we the next generation will not fail
our own kids we will make this change
happen if not today then tomorrow if not
tomorrow next year take it from us you
created a mess with us but we will make
this world safer for our children again
you know I understand that this girl
went through something absolutely
horrible but the world is significantly
safer for kids growing up today than it
has been at any time literally in human
history and if she thinks that she's
gonna be able to ram through gun control
because something bad happened to her I
have another thing coming for her she
was with Wednesday's demonstration and
there marched for our lives movement on
March 24th in Washington young voices
are being heard
how will the nation's adult respond
hopefully by amplifying their demand
never again so first of all I love the
use of the Holocaust terminology never
again to describe what are rare
instances of horrific terrorism and not
quite the same thing but as opposed to
you know like an organized government
effort to slaughter six million Jews not
quite the same thing as people who being
allowed to own guns because it is their
right to do so and then a couple of bad
people going and doing really horrific
things with those guns not quite the
same thing as the Holocaust but all
right and then they quote a bunch of
high school juniors right and we're
supposed to believe that all of these
high schoolers are the wisest and
greatest among us now again tragedy does
not confer expertise I've said this
about Jimmy Kimmel and his son just
because something bad happened to you in
your life does not make you an expert on
the underlying issue
hi Jimmy Kimmel had a surgeon perform
the surgery on his son he didn't perform
the surgery himself because he
understands that just because he was
suffering doesn't mean that expertise
goes out the window
the same holds true of gun control just
because you witnessed something awful
happen at your school does not mean you
know what you are talking about when it
comes to the best public policy to stop
such shootings but the New York Times
again they want to use these kids as as
political human shields and so here is
what this is they turn over their
editorial page to these
and then they quote them right Alfonzo
called her own junior no clue no kid
should be afraid to go to school no kid
should be afraid to walk outside and no
kid should have to worry about being
shot now that's why I'm marching ok no
kid should have to worry about leukemia
no kid should have to worry about
disease no kid should have to worry
about murder no kid should have to worry
about anything terrible that's true I
mean now that would be great
unfortunately we live in a world where
there are evil people the question is
how do you stop them we all want to stop
those evil people
okay how about Ali she he not Ally
Sheedy right how is she the children of
the senior in high school the children
you pissed off will not forget this in
the voting booth don't doubt the power
of the younger generation because we are
a force to be reckoned with yeah every
young generation says this sometimes
they are sometimes they're not but again
the idea that everybody who's young is
solidly behind a particular gun proposal
is just not true my polling emma
gonzalez is one of the people who's been
featured the most in the media and and
subsequently the media have been just
enamored of her twitter followers
because she has gotten this big twitter
bump she went from like nothing to 1.1
million because she was featured on
ellen and a bunch of other shows
so they quote her maybe the adults have
gotten used to saying it is what it is
but if US students have learned anything
if well first of all if we students have
learned anything emma right if you maybe
should learn some grammar but if US
students have learned anything it's that
if you don't study you will fail you
should study grammar or you'll fail and
in this case if you actively do nothing
people continually continually end up
dead so it's time to start doing
something we are going to be the kids
you read about in textbooks not because
we're gonna be another statistic about
mastery in america but because we're
going to be the last mass shooting i
fervently wish that this were true I
fervently hope that this is true but
just because we all want to stop mass
shootings doesn't mean I agree with them
a Gonzalez's prescription I mean all of
this is basically Bernie Sanders style
politics I've ripped on Bernie Sanders's
Twitter account for a long time because
Bernie Sanders his Twitter account is
largely Bernie Sanders just saying
things like there are rich people and
poor people the would should not be like
this is it well okay fine but you can do
about it and this is the same thing it's
there shouldn't be shootings of children
yes we all agree now your proposal
please I mean Jacqueline Corrine junior
high school shouldn't be hashtags every
other day Jose Iglesias senior more
prayer Jesus God and compassion won't
bring back the victims that sadly lost
their lives I'm not sure anyone was
making the contention that more God was
going to bring back children who died it
won't bring back the sense of security
that my fellow peers and I lost the only
way to
get that back is through gun control
starting now weird because there is
significant gun control all over Chicago
and people don't feel particularly
secure hey gun control doesn't make
people feel secure lack of being shot
makes people feel secure the only reason
that you would embrace gun control over
for example more armed security guards
is for political reasons so make an
argument I love this madison leo the
children will become leaders as the
leaders have become children I don't
even know what that means again and
again it's it's it's always selective so
the New York Times did turn over one of
the one of the editorials on their
editorial page to a sophomore at
Randolph high school a junior at Toms
River North High School and a senior at
Marlborough High School all new jersey
again this is just political human
shield stuff right they're going to
bring out a bunch of young kids and then
suggest these kids know something better
because they are kids which is weird and
they right we are generation Zetas in
the New York Times the generation after
Millennials we outnumber them by nearly
1 million and maybe the largest cohort
of future American spenders since the
baby boomers we have more than 30
billion in spending power and wield
enormous influence and family spending
our spending power will only increase as
we begin to earn our own wages we will
flex our muscles at the ballot box too
many high school seniors will cast their
first ballots this November and in 2020
a majority of today's high school
students will most likely be able to
vote in their first presidential
election let us remind politicians like
Donald Trump Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell
who accept donations from the NRA and
oppose efforts to restrict gun purchases
that we are the future leaders and
voters of this country
well I'm sure that some of you are and
some of you or not I mean there are lots
of people who vote there are lots people
they don't vote there lots of people who
lead there are lots of people who don't
there are lots of people who are young
who will join the NRA there are lots of
people who won't let us remind
corporations like FedEx that provide
discounts to NRA members and we are
their future customers again this is not
an argument this is a moral appeal right
it's an emotional appeal now the reason
that I'm reading all of this from the
New York Times is to demonstrate that
they're rather selective in the folks
that they choose to feature because
there are a lot of young listeners to
venture pyroshow there a lot of young
people who listen to the show something
like 70 to 75% of our audience is under
the age of 35 with a very
disproportionately young audience of
which we're very proud and we have tons
and tons of high schoolers who listen to
this show and I've been getting
overwhelmingly one message from my
emailers over the last two weeks and
they I mean this I'm talking about
scores of emails I'm talking about
probably more than a hundred emails from
high schoolers over the last week
alone and today many many more after I
wrote this piece Corner saying that they
are that they are upset with the media
coverage of this mass walkout and asking
for advice on how to deal with it I've
gotten lots and lots of emails from from
these folks so here are some of the
emails and I want to read the emails
from some of these students who are not
going to be featured in the New York
Times I want to read some of the emails
from these students who are not going to
be shown on network news tonight
I'll read the emails from some of the
students who are going to be ignored and
castigated and told that they are worse
that they are worse human beings because
they disagree with gun control I want to
give them a voice because the media the
rest of media certainly are not giving
these kids a voice and I am speaking
with these kids I promise you far more
often than the Editorial Board of the
New York Times as the editorial the New
York Times hasn't talked to a person
under the age of 40 except for like this
last couple days in years I'm talking to
people under the age of 20 every single
day because I want to read some of the
things that they've been sending to me
and let them speak okay so I'm gonna
turn over my show to them in just one
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at wonder ease new
show
this is war okay so there's a new
podcast out there from Wonder a podcast
network it's called this is Wharton into
sharing the personal stories from brave
men and women who serve in our armed
forces these are first-hand accounts of
what it's like to fight and survive
combat in Afghanistan in Iraq what it's
like to protect our freedom the bonds
that are formed psychological toll it
takes on people to fight and what it is
like to return home trying to figure out
how you fit in and how you heal the
physical and emotional wounds from time
in combat it's really moving moving
podcast it is a deeply effective and
necessary podcast in the first episode
we meet a guy named Ian Mirren's and a
month before his senior year in high
school he joined the Marines and he
signed up for the military and that was
August of 2001 how we see a life changed
very much the next month so if you want
to hear his story go over to this is war
on Apple podcast wherever you're
listening to this podcast this is war
vailable check out this is war hit the
subscribe button or visit one dorito FM
slash man that's wonder with Y dot F M
slash been subscribe listen it's really
worth your time and again it'll give you
just a greater appreciation for what it
is that these that that our heroes do on
a daily basis check it out wonder is
this is war podcast totally worth the
subscribe alrighty so now I want to read
some the emails that I've been getting
from high schoolers all over the country
who are deeply upset and and deeply
angry that there are so many
people who are castigating them as bad
people because they disagree I mean I'm
looking at just in the last hour in the
last hour I've received 15 separate
emails in one hour before the show from
various high school students who are
asking about what they should do during
these walk outs because they're
frustrated and they're upset they feel
like they're being ignored here's a high
school junior today quote honestly it's
like the women's March there's no single
consolidated argument just a loose
collection of rants that obscure the
main point from a sixteen-year-old high
school girl quote I was planning on not
participating in the walkout I do not
see the point in leaving class to simply
walk outside stand and talk with peers
for 17 minutes and return to class the
act of walking out of class to protest
school violence does not seem to have a
target audience even though they may
have a news crew it is doubtful the
students in Florida will see the actions
of our schools walk out as a stand with
solidarity I also support the Second
Amendment and I see this walkout as
another opportunity for students and
their parents to attack that Amendment
and I support again my and my opposition
to gun control I do see that my refusal
to participate may be seen as
unsympathetic or cruel my brother who's
a freshman is being pressured in class
to participate from a 17 year old high
school student tomorrow my school is
having a walkout at 10 a.m. for the 17
students who were killed in parkland
Florida shooting the walkout however
here at my school is not really about
that it is being promoted by an anti-gun
leftist political agenda that I just
don't and can't support especially using
the 17 kids that were my age as a
platform I was wondering what you would
say to people who want to call me
insensitive and a terrible person I mean
my initial response to that is anybody
who calls you insensitive and a terrible
person because you disagree on political
matters is insensitive and a terrible
person hey here's from another 17 year
old high school student the reason I'm
emailing is because my school is having
a walkout on March 14th they say in an
e-mail that this walkout is to advocate
for gun reform but they also say that we
are walking to honor the victims of the
Parkland massacre I'm in favor of
walking to honor the victims but not in
favor of promoting gun reform I feel
like I have to choose between going
against my political values or looking
like a bad person
I need help what do I do I'm getting
emails like this literally minute by
minute now from another high school or
my high school is participating in the
walkout on Wednesday I am unsure what to
do I'm very against gun control I don't
want to protest Congress for something
they're doing right if that makes sense
however I don't want to be singled out
by students as someone who quote doesn't
care about the students who died should
I participate and conform to avoid
humiliation and honor the students or
should I remain in class alone I don't
know if the walkout is more about gun
control or honoring the students I mean
I could literally do this all day I
could
really do this all day here's one that
came in in the last four minutes okay
hello my name is I'm gonna leave out his
name and and his class because I don't
want to get in trouble is I saw your
tweet about the unheard conservative
students and it is very relatable
there was a walk out of my school today
a large majority of the students sat in
the gym instead of walking out this is
school about 1800 people fortunately my
school would not allow protests of
liberal students had to mascot as a
memorial but the motives were still very
much apparent the local media only
covered the minority of the students
participating in the walkout I have a
question as to how to get my own and my
conservative peers voices heard can you
post about that or something related to
that sometime please I'm happy to talk
about it right now this is in the last
10 minutes okay these are all emails
from the last 10 minutes alone I'm not
even screening them I'm just pulling
them up from my mailbag right now this
guy this guy is an in Anthony's has been
first let me say I'm a big fan of the
show on the website second I'm a 16 year
old sophomore in Philadelphia our scoot
student council in collaboration with
our school administration organized and
walk out today to remember and pray for
the victims of the recent shooting
however in my opinion this walkout
quickly shifted into a walkout for gun
control similar to the walk outs
occurring across the nation we
thankfully had the option to choose to
change died which I did as a Catholic I
stayed inside and said a prayer for the
victims of the shooting however I
refused to go outside to protest gun
control because I'm a proud Second
Amendment supporter I believe we have
the constitutional right to bear arms
and therefore it shall not be infringed
upon just thought I would share my story
regarding this walkout again thanks for
your mail I'm getting these things like
they're coming in faster than I can
actually read all of them because there
are tons of them coming in over and over
and over and all this and and here is
the thing right and here's the thing the
media won't read you any of these emails
because the media wants to promote this
agenda the media wants to suggest that
the only reason in the world that you
would not walk out with these students
is because you hate the students and you
don't care about the students and by the
way we support gun control now in a
second I'm gonna talk about the suppose
it agenda of this gun control walkout in
a second I'm gonna talk about that so
let's let's jump right on the women's
March is organizing this first of all
the women's March is organized by some
of the worst people on earth three of
the four people who are women's March
co-chairs are open supporters of Louis
Farrakhan and still the women's March
has not really disciplined them the
women's March is not to motive them
though these these three people have not
come out and apologized for their
support of Lewis Farrakhan the women's
March put out sort of a ridiculously
vague statement about how they want to
be tolerant but they didn't go any
further than that
the women's March is a group of radicals
who like to obscure their message by
suggesting that you have to walk out in
support of women or have to walk out in
support of children but here's what
they're actually something for so if you
actually go to the women's march website
and they have something called hashtag
enough national school walk out our
demands hey you can't demands anything
it's a democracy you can elect people
who do what you want but your demands
are going to fall on deaf ears because
it's just you shouting at the wind with
media support here are their demands
quote demand one banning assault weapons
and high-capacity magazines in this
country there's a fine line between
wanting to be protected and wanting to
intimidate others it's all in the title
assault weapons don't protect they harm
and too easily these deadly weapons can
be bought sold and distributed within
the borders of our nation how can we
enjoy freedom if our own country
condones the selling of deadly
military-grade reference weapons which
threaten our very existence the right to
bear arms should not be the right to
kill no one says you have the right to
kill you idiots and the notion that
assault weapons are even a definable
category is ridiculous you know what a
military-grade arm is any rifle ever hey
those are all military-grade because at
some point in history all rifles have
been used for military purposes but I
guess that we're supposed to pretend
that this makes any sense demand to
expanding background checks to all gun
sales with one in five gun purchases
being a no-questions-asked purchase
dangerous people have the ability to
easily purchase guns from private
sellers at gun shows over the internet
and even through magazines in states
that don't require background checks
well this is again I'm a statement of
law the statement is that if you're
going to buy from a federally licensed
firearms dealer over the internet at a
gun show or anywhere else you have to go
through a federal background check the
well-researched connection between a
history of domestic violence and gun
violence combined with expanded
background checks could have prevented
much of the gun violence we experience
in this country we know states that
required background checks on all
handgun sales or permits had 35% fewer
gun deaths per capita than states
without that background check
requirement well I don't know where you
are getting that particular statistic
and I would like to I haven't had a
chance to actually vet that's this is
that comes from the Giffords Law Center
to Prevent Gun Violence but I think that
you know these statistics do not bear
out that one factor in a multifactorial
analysis explains the states that have
fewer gun deaths per capita right that
that background check on handgun sales
is that you'd have to explain that there
are a bunch of people
buying privately and then shooting
people again those statistics are not
available as a general rule the Man
three passing gun violence restraining
order to law made this one I actually
support right this one they say time and
time again we hear people commenting on
how they saw it coming or always knew it
be him gun violence restraining orders
would provide a consistent and localized
system for people to provide reasonable
suspicion to local courts resulting in
the expeditious removal of guns from
those showing signs of potential to harm
themselves or others followed by due
process okay
nothing first of all that is a wild
misstatement of the law at the very end
that the the due process comes after the
seizure of the guns no the new process
comes before the seizure of the guns and
then the due process continues after the
seizure of the guns oh yeah but the then
they get to the final one and this
undermines all their others right demand
for stop militarizing law enforcement
act in 2017 there were only 14 days when
police didn't kill someone so it's
important that when we talk about gun
violence we not forget state sanctioned
gun violence that disproportionately
impacts black or brown communities black
people make up 13% of the US population
yet constitute one-quarter of those
killed by police hey now I mentioned
here black people also constitute one
half of all murder victims in the United
States and approximately half of all
murderers in the United States this is
not a statement about race being
implicitly tied with violence but so
long as you are citing race in
connection with violence statistics it's
important to note that police actually
statistically undershoots minority
people they don't overshoot minority
people if you actually connect that with
the levels of violence occurring in the
minority community this act would slow
the process of turning our neighborhoods
into war zones by preventing the police
from having the weaponry and equipment
of invading armies so here's the
hilarious parts they want to disarm
everyone presumably leaving all of our
safety in the hands of the police and
then they want to disarm the police who
do you think is actually gonna disarm
all those people do you think that it's
gonna be a bunch of unarmed people who
walk up to two armed people in Texas and
take away their guns do you think that
when a school shooter shows up if the
police don't have weapons they're gonna
go in we've been told by these same
people that a guy with a handgun can't
even go up with a guy against the guy
with the ar-15 if that's the case then
why would you possibly want to disarm
the cops but this is what the women's
March is it's a radical radical group
and it gets even better I mean at some
point in here they actually talk about
how they want to oppose international
violence or something like that this is
an agenda driven March masquerading as a
as a broad statement of sympathy for
students
I hate that sort of conflation because
it's just not true okay in a second I'm
gonna move on to Pennsylvania 18th and I
want to also give a piece of advice to
all the students who are experiencing
the walk outs today but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix leap so as I've said many many
times I am very bad at sleeping
there's particularly true when I'm on
the road because I miss my helix sleep
mattress helix sleep gives you something
that does not exist anywhere else a
mattress personalized to your unique
preferences and sleeping style that
won't set you back thousands of dollars
you go to helix sleep comm /ban when you
take their simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz they build you a custom
mattress and that will be the it's the
best thing you've ever slept on it
really is fantastic with a more
fantastic mattress in our room we moved
it out because the helix sleep mattress
is better for couples they'll even
personalize each side of the mattress
and here's the best part
you can try it for a hundred nights and
if you don't love it they will pick it
up and refund you in full okay the
custom mattress arrives so right to your
door in the week shipping is completely
free unpack it from package it
automatically inflates it and it's ready
to go go to Hilux sleep calm / bed right
now you got fifty dollars toward your
custom mattress that's helix sleep calm
/ Ben 50 bucks order custom mattress
again helix sleep calm / Ben for 50
bucks off your order there's a lot of
more expensive mattresses out there and
they're not as good helix sleep calm /
Ben make sure that it's personalized
make sure that it is made just for you
that's what helix does helix sleep comm
/ menus that / Ben you get 50 bucks
toward your custom mattress plus it lets
them know that we saw you okay so for
all those students who are asking what
they should do during this walkout given
all the propaganda that's surrounding
the walkout here is my answer right my
answer is that the my answer is that you
should go to the walkout so that you're
not perceived as uncaring and you should
bring with you a sign and the shine
should say my and the sign should say
something like I care about I care about
children's lives I care about my life
protect my life arm teachers right
protect my life arm law-abiding people
protect my life more school security
right put your message right out there
show that you can do both it's like I
said at CPAC everybody in the room at
CPAC most of the vast majority from her
second amendment support is very strong
you know I said to them raise your hand
if you care about what happened in
parkland every hand goes up and I said
raise your hand if you care about the
Second Amendment every hand goes up the
media seem to want to believe that these
two things cannot coexist they do
coexist show that they coexist go to the
walkout and carry us
saying he stand with the Second
Amendment and you stand with the kids
the media will ignore you but at least
you'll have made your point I think
that's sort of important ok so last
night the other big news aside from the
impending school walkout was the results
from the pennsylvania 18th congressional
district so Connor lamb apparently has
won that seat or apparently it looks
like he's going to win that seat he is
the Democrat in that district that
district went to Donald Trump by 20
points 20 ok and it has flipped all the
way Democrat this makes just another
data point in a dataset that is really
really bad for conservatives according
to fivethirtyeight.com
in the seven special elections that have
taken place since 2016 there's been an
average swing in favor of Democrats of
16 points hey the way they're measuring
that swing is they average the
differences between how this
constituencies in these particular
districts voted and how the country
overall voted in the last two
presidential elections so the average
swing has been 16 points there was a
thirty one point swing for example in
the Alabama US Senate race in which doug
jones ended up becoming the senator the
democrat ended up becoming the senator
the same thing happened in Pennsylvania
last night there's a 20-point swing in
that race okay this is not good news for
Republicans it's actually very bad news
for Republicans pretty obviously and
Republicans are trying to make all sorts
of excuses for this they're trying to
explain why this is not such a big deal
one of the explanations is put forward
by Kaley mcenany who's a big Trump fan
big Trump acolyte and she says listen
Conor lamb won because he was basically
running as a Republican Connor Lam has
essentially run as a Republican he's
pro-gun he says he's personally pro-life
he says he's Pro coal he's Pro tariffs
he's anti Nancy Pelosi imagine that the
Democratic candidate who's against Nancy
Pelosi the Minority Leader he has made
himself into essentially a Republican so
you have a Republican and named and a
Republican and truth running against one
another okay so you know this is the
argument is that it's really not a big
deal because Connor Lam is basically
Republican McConnell M is not a
Republican he's a pro-abortion Democrat
he says he's personally pro-life but he
is in favor of abortion being legalized
all the way across the board he is not
pro gun control so he opposes gun
control this is not an argument that
Republicans are gonna do well in 2018
it's an argument that if Democrats are
not stupid and they run people tailored
to their districts they will do better
right if they're on John Assaf in the
Georgia sixth District if they run a
Nancy Pelosi fan who's not from inside
the district they're going to lose if
they're on Doug Jones
who is perceived as moderate in Alabama
even though he is not if they were on
Connor lamb who's perceived as moderate
in the Pennsylvania 18th then they will
win so the argument here is not that
Republicans are doing fine because this
Democrat ran a conservative campaign the
point is a Democrat just one who caucus
with Democrats in a district that no
Republican has lost no Republican has
lost in 20 years and no Republican has
won by fewer than 15 points in the last
20 years they just lost that district
now listen there were some factors
moving against the Republicans in this
district Tim Murphy was the former
congressman who stepped down he stepped
down specifically because he had knocked
up his mistress and then he had told her
to get an abortion then he had to step
down that's never good for the
Republican who's gonna have to step in
but in their art +20 district that
really should not make a difference
there are a lot of bad signs for
Republicans here the reason I'm saying
this is not god forbid celebrit ory I
don't want Republicans to lose the house
I think it'd be terrible as I've said
many times on the show for Republicans
to lose the house because I think the
Democrats would then start passing all
sorts of bills and I think President
Trump would be sorely tempted to sign a
lot of those bills I'm not sure that
Trump is gonna stand between the
Democrats and their policy priorities if
he thinks he's gonna get some good
headlines out of it particularly if he
can swivel to the middle I think and
give Democrats a bunch of things they
want and get about I don't you're good
headlines Trump likes pleasing the
people who are in the room with him is
I'm very perturbed by the possibility of
a Democratic Congress but and it's
fairly obvious at this point the
Democrats do have a major enthusiasm
advantage again in those seven special
elections in 2017 Democrats gains an
average of 16 percent last night they
gain 20% just over 2016 so in a year
like one year that district shifted by
20 points and one of the reasons for
that is obviously the Republican
enthusiasm is really low there's only 60
percent of the turnout that they got in
2016 Trump isn't on the ballot this time
so you know off your elections are
usually bad for the president in power
but there's sort of regression to the
mean that said Trump's unpopularity
doesn't help right Trump actually went
and campaign for Rick Ciccone didn't
make one bit of difference not one and
here's a war statistic for Republicans
this is an hour plus 20 district they're
118 seats held by Republicans that Trump
won by fewer than 20 points there were
closer districts than this district now
does that mean Republicans are gonna
lose 100 seats no it doesn't mean that
Republicans will win the vast majority
of those seats but Democrats only need
to pick up 24 seats in order to win the
house so you have to say at this point
that statistically speak
in a data-driven way they are the
favourites to pick up the house which
means House Speaker Nancy Pelosi god
help us okay second point here Trump's
popularity does actually matter so
there's been a lot of talk a lot of
loose talk about the idea that Trump can
be as unpopular as he wants to be polls
don't matter his base will support him
his base will get out there and vote his
base is not big enough to win
congressional elections
it just isn't his base was not big
enough to win a popular vote and
congressional elections are gonna look a
lot more like a popular vote than they
are like the electoral college because
again they're within smaller districts
right the electoral college means that
if you win the state of Florida by one
vote you win all of their electoral
votes but congressional districts are
much more localized so that means that
national polling you know these sort of
generic congressional ballots they do
matter all right if there's a generic
congressional ballot that shows the
Democrats are up by about nine which is
where they're saying it is right now
Democrats win back the house in a pretty
easy walk Trump's popularity is a drag
here my presidents with low popularity
ratings depress turnout for their own
side and from as a gift for increasing
turnout on the other side at least now
the Democrats realized that he could be
President the reason that the Democrats
instructable for Hilary's because
Hillary was awful but also because they
believed it was a foregone conclusion
that Hillary's gonna win and they
believe that if they stay at home it
would make a difference Hillary was
gonna walk over Trump by 10 points but
they were wrong and I don't think
they're gonna make that mistake again
so Trump had better pull his pull his
plummeting popularity ratings out from
out from the sewer Democrats are also as
I say running better candidates Connor
lamb is a much better candidate than
John Asaf like rent lam ran it is true
as a soft Republican but you know the
fact that he ran is a soft Republican
demonstrates the Democrats may not be
quite as stupid as the intersectionality
Laden politics they've been promoting
would suggest which is you know
devastating for Republicans we've been
hoping that Democrats are going to
basically you know cave in on themselves
they will they will run the worst
candidates in human history again and
again and again and again they will in
some districts but not in all districts
and you can't count on them making this
many mistakes you just can't so you know
all of this is bad news and I want to
talk a little bit more about that in
just a second I also want to talk about
my friend steven crowder being suspended
from Twitter and apparently from YouTube
also which is just absurd I'm gonna talk
about all that in just a second but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm so for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily Wired
icon you get the rest of the show live
get the rest of Clavin the show live
Knowles's show live you get to be part
of our mail
on Friday so if you want your mail
answered then actually go to the mailbag
by becoming a subscriber and $9.99 a
month the annual subscription comes
along with this the very greatest in
tumblers the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler you will enjoy it you will
treasure it it'll make your morning it
will make your evening it will make your
entire life actually it's just that good
check that out ninety-nine dollars a
year so cheaper than the monthly
subscription also you just want to
listen later iTunes SoundCloud Google
Play stitcher any of those please
subscribe please leave us a review we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
all righty so there are a lot of people
who just want to ignore the data in
Pennsylvania 18 there are a lot of
people who want to believe that
everything is going to be fine there are
a couple factors cutting against this
Trump actually has got one pretty well
but his actual governance has been
pretty decent for the first year we got
a big tax cut the economy is doing
pretty well all those things are true he
still just lost a district right
seconded just lost a district that was
our plus 20 and from visited that
district all of which is to suggest that
things are not going to get better for
president Trump and not unless President
Trump makes a market shift and how he
approaches politics which is very
unlikely at this point because the
economy is booming like what could get
better at this point really what what
could what policy wise for all those
policy wonks who think that everything's
gonna get better this was supposed to be
one of the districts that was going to
love president Trump's tariffs right
this is a Pittsburgh suburb this is the
area that Trump was going to bring back
steel manufacturing with tariffs and
Republicans just lost it so what does
that say it says that Trump is about at
the high-water mark of what he can do
politically to help himself the economy
is doing really well there isn't any
major foreign crisis on the map we're
not involved in a long-lasting war
outside of Afghanistan which has been
going on at low levels for the last 20
years nothing has happened
that would drive from Sapru Ville
writing into the toilet right there
hasn't been an economic collapse like
killed george w bush's last term and
there hasn't been anything like that so
what is Trump supposed to do policy-wise
the answer is nothing which means a lot
of this is personality it means that
Trump is going to have to stop kind of
emitting this odor of chaos he's gonna
have to stop with the with the troll
Lorie I think he's gonna have to unite
from proceeded into the background if
Trump just became part of the part of
the wall the part of the wall paper I
think the Democrats would have a harder
time getting their turnout out the
reason they're getting their turnout up
is because people dislike Trump in the
same way that Republicans disliked Obama
but probably more so it helps
Republicans in 2010 that Obama that
Obama was the president and it will help
Democrats since once he 18 that Trump is
that is the President of the United
States again I can like a lot of what
Trump is doing and also recognized that
he is a political liability in a lot of
these districts there's a report out
today that only two Republicans across
the country actually want Trump to
campaign with them again that's not
unique to Trump and people who are
saying well look
that's just cuz Trump's terrible there
were a lot of Democrats who didn't want
Obama anywhere near them in 2010 in 2012
and 2014 in 2016 right didn't want Obama
putting the stink of his presidency on
them then what Obama you know spending
his days blathering about gun control
and health care reform and then coming
to their districts where they were
running a really narrow race well the
same thing can hold true for Trump that
a lot of Republicans may not want the
the stench of Trump on them and so
they're trying to avoid him but Trump
demands loyalty and so if you don't show
enough loyalty like they're stuck
between a rock and a hard place at least
Obama had the brains to recognize that
if Democrats didn't want to campaign
with him that was probably because they
thought they were gonna lose and he
needed them in the Congress Trump is the
kind of guy who if you say I don't mr.
president love you I don't need you in
my district it's gonna be a problem for
me if you say that's a president Trump
there's a solid shot that within five
minutes he's on Twitter blasting you as
disloyal and suggesting that you be
primary so Republicans are sort of stuck
between a rock and a hard place on Trump
but listen not all of this is about
Trump again there's an average loss of
you know 20-plus seats in these
congressional off year elections but it
does not help when people insist that
data doesn't matter that polls don't
matter then nothing matters I did just
because the polls were off on the state
level in 2016 does not mean that all
polls are fake the national polls in
2016 were actually pretty close to the
money the polls last night in
Pennsylvania were very very close they
said this was a dead heat it wasn't dead
heat the races separated for like a
thousand votes so before we just start
ignoring data because it is convenient
to us to ignore data then you know I
think that we should probably look at
that data and analyze whether or not any
of this is is a good idea okay so quick
note on my friend Stephen Connor so my
friend steven crowder has now been
suspended from Twitter for violating its
hateful conduct terms he's apparently
also been suspended from YouTube which
is insane right so now they they posted
an X out by Southwest video of spend
computer infiltrating a gender-fluid
panel when Twitter suspended Stephens
account so they've said that he needs to
delete the tweets that violate the rules
they've suspended the account for 12
hours
okay here's what what Crowder's website
is saying here's what we think happened
the original video that went out didn't
have the word bleep it's it's the the F
word for forgave people soft bleep the
original video was immediately pulled
from YouTube Twitter and Facebook
as the studio team added bleeps for the
offensive content after the bleeps were
added into the video the studio--
reuploaded the south by south southwest
undercover video back to YouTube and
Facebook
when knocking Jared shared the video
with the bleeps added an information
blurred
he was also suspended which means
Twitter didn't find that word offensive
they've found the general concept of the
video offensive so what what exactly is
the video so apparently the video is fun
computer right a fake character who is
forced to crash an LGBTQ gender
nonconformity meetup at South by
Southwest ok this this tape has now been
removed from YouTube it's just a comedy
video alright it's typical Crowder
alright Crowder's the guy does
Bane alright this is his shtick he's a
comedian comedians do lots of stuff that
walks right up to the edge and sometimes
crosses over the edge this is a reason
that you're gonna be banned from Twitter
suspended from Twitter Louis Farrakhan
is tweeting openly and Lewis Farrakhan
is tweeting openly and he's met a crap
on Twitter every single day he's not
been suspended and his counterparts on
the right people like Richard Spencer
who I even hesitate to call of the right
you know Richard Spencer who is who is
you know so the white version of Louis
Farrakhan in verse right Richard Spencer
has been suspended from Twitter I don't
think he's on Twitter anymore I think
he's been banned from Twitter the same
thing holds true of my lowly innopolis
now I'm not in favor of any of these
people being banned from Twitter even
though I despise all but I think that it
is completely absurd that Steven is
getting knocked off these platforms
because Steven happens to be a
conservative comedian where if you were
a left-wing comedian and you said
exactly the same words about Christians
everything would be totally fine you
said the same words about Jews
everything would be totally fine this
double standard that exists in social
media is really dangerous it's one of
the reasons why Facebook YouTube Twitter
and Google all of these outlets seem to
be targeting conservative content right
now
conservatives better get on their horse
I mean we better start building some of
our own outlets because the reality is
that if we don't build some open thread
outlets if we don't build some open
source outlets that allow people to post
what they want to post with some very
very minut restrictions then the left
will simply castigate everything as hate
speech okay this is one of the things
that's been so funny in the recent
couple of weeks but left keep saying
well you know you know you're worried
about crackdowns on free speech on
college campuses you're worried about
intolerant leftist but if you look at
the polls people on campus say they're
for free speech right but those same
polls show that these people say that
they are against what they call racist
speech but the problem is they then
define racist
is anything they disagree with so you
have a definitional problem that's very
serious yeah the same thing is happening
to Crowder here lumping in Crowder with
milo gianopolous or lumping in christina
hoff sommers with Richard Spencer and
some people on the Left are trying to do
is just absurd it's insane it's happened
to me also it's disgusting if you're not
gonna make any sort of honest
intellectual distinction between these
categories then you don't deserve to
have a platform your platform should
fall apart right jack over its Twitter
get on here and get on your game dude I
mean this is just it's just ridiculous
there's no excuse for it whatsoever
all right so I mean while President
Trump is is he decided to inspect the
border yesterday so he comes and he
inspects the border wall here is what it
looked like when he inspected border
wall prototypes in San Diego president
Trump there in San Diego California
taking a look at the border wall
prototypes in the meantime I just want
to let you know that more than 400 firms
submitted proposals to be included here
six companies built a total of eight
prototypes the prototypes you can see a
lot of them there in the background are
18 to 30 feet high okay so Trump goes
and visits the prototypes the purpose of
this of course is to show the Democrats
that he's serious about building the
wall even though we have not had one
foot yet built of the wall the president
then talked a little bit about the wall
and for some odd reason it started
talking about the Jamaican bobsled team
or the Mexican mountain climbing team
like really this is the thing that
happened the larger it is the better it
is because it's very hard to get over
the top it's really deterrent from
getting over the top who would think who
would think but getting over the top is
easy these are like professional
mountain climbers you're incredible
climbers they can't climb some of these
walls some of them they can those are
the walls were not using okay mr.
president thank you for that
dissertation on the climbing capacity of
Mexican illegal immigrants just just
well done
don't even know what's happening there
that was not the only weird thing that
Trump said yesterday he also pushed what
he called the space for so he he floated
the idea of creating a new military
branch to fight wars in space now to be
fair to President Trump he's not the
only person who has actually mentioned
this before this has been mentioned by a
number of legislators the idea of
creating a space force but it is kind of
funny when Trump says it so here he is
space is a war fighting domain
just like the land air and sea we may
even have a space force develop another
one space force we have the Air Force
while the space force we have the army
the Navy you know I was saying it the
other day cuz we're doing a tremendous
amount of work in space I said maybe we
need a new force we'll go with the space
force and I was not really serious and
then I said what a great idea maybe
we'll have to do that that could happen
that could be the big breaking story
look at all those people back there look
at that what exactly is happening I'm
what now a space force well the good
news is the President Trump is already
cut a commercial for space force here's
what it looks like young people from all
over the globe are joining up to fight
for the future I'm doing my part they're
doing their part are you join the mobile
infantry and save the world service
guarantees citizenship
there it is bed of course is from a
starship trooper so the President of the
United States promoting space force okay
fine whatever it it's probably not the
worst idea in the world actually so
there's that okay meanwhile the
president is breaking news in the last
few minutes the president the United
States about to appoint as the head of
his National Economic Council I the the
the famed free trader Larry Kudlow which
just goes to show you that Trump really
doesn't have policies he just has people
he likes so Larry Kudlow is basically
Gary Cohn except his name is Larry
Kudlow so Gary Cohen you're recall was
ousted from the National Economic
Council head he was supposed to be the
guy who stood up to Trump's anti-free
trade agenda and he stepped down after
Trump said that he was going to push
forward with his steel and aluminum
tariffs Kudlow has been an ardent fruit
trader for years he says that free trade
is the bulwark of the international
system
Trump's appointing him to replace cone
which is a really weird pick i listen i
like larry cudlow i think that larry
cudlow is correct about all of this
here's the report from CNBC president
Donald Trump plans to name Kudlow as his
top economic adviser sources told CNBC
Trump could announce his decision is to
choose Kudlow as his National Economic
Council director as soon as Thursday the
CNBC senior contributor and honored
personality will replace Gary Cohen who
left the White House earlier this month
amid disagreements about tariffs on
steel and aluminum imports now I can't
imagine that Larry is gonna go in there
and that he's immediately going to turn
into a tariff fanatic that he's suddenly
going to turn it into Peter Navarro it
is good news I mean this is this means
the Peter Navarro isn't the head of the
NEC which would just be a disaster but
it is pretty astonishing when the Trump
is willing to appoint somebody who
disagrees with him on all the policy
because he saw him on TV which basically
is what it sounds like here it sounds
like that that's exactly what it sounds
like it sounds like there is some sort
of there's some sort of personal
relationship between Trump and Kudlow
and so he's gonna have Kudlow as part of
his team which is again not the best way
to foreign policy
this just breaking and that Kudlow has
accepted the job and the alert is out on
the Washington Post so that is pretty
that is pretty hilarious okay another
hilarious news Katy Perry is responsible
for a me-too moment so Katy Perry is a
judge on the new American Idol and
there's a guy who sang for her he is a
virgin who's never been kissed his name
is Benjamin glaze he's a 19 year old
kasher from Enid Ohio and apparently
he and apparently he sang beautifully on
American Idol and Katy Perry loved it so
much that she came over and kissed him
right on the lips right moments before
his audition and said instead it came to
Sochi it wasn't even after he sang he
said it was a tad bit uncomfortable his
first kiss was rite-of-passage he didn't
put him off with consideration he said I
wanted to save it for my first
relationship I want it to be special
what I have done it if she said would
you kiss me no I would have said no I
know a lot of guys would be like heck
yeah but for me I was raised in a
conservative family I was uncomfortable
immediately I wanted my first kiss to be
special the scene with the kiss was part
of a two-night season opener for the new
American Idol which is now on ABC after
it was kicked off of Fox and the new
panel of celebrities is a Katy Perry
Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan and it's
hosted by Ryan Seacrest in the segments
that featured mr. glaze he was shown
waiting around anticipation for his
audition with other hopefuls as he
entered the studio guitar slung over his
shoulder lookin a bit starstruck he said
he enjoyed his work as a cashier because
it let him eat cute girls and have you
kissed a girl and liked it asked Mr
Bryan making a quite reference to Miss
Perry's first hit single I kissed a girl
mr. glaze said that he had not and he
said I've never been in relationship I
can't kiss a girl without being in a
relationship and then she stood up and
she said come here right now and then
she said one on the cheek and she and
she smiled and then she asked for
another kiss complaining he had even
made the smush sound as he moved toward
her cheek again miss Perry swung her
face toward him and kissed him quickly
on the lips and then she raised her arms
and victory okay a me-too moment that no
one will care about because obviously
even though the contestant was not into
it even though he didn't want it Katy
Perry is a hot liberal so we're allowed
to pretend that that's all okay yep
that's the way that it works imagine
that had been a conservative dude doing
that to a virginal feminist and imagine
how that would have gone the answer is
it would it would not have gone okay
time for a couple of things that I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like today there
is a brand new book out called the
escape artist from my friend Brad
Meltzer and and Brad Meltzer is a is a
terrific author I mean he's written
thrillers before it's been several years
since he wrote a thriller so this is
first thriller in quite a long while
he's also the author of bunch of books
I've recommended on the program for kids
I am George Washington I am Jackie
Robinson I'm Martin Luther King these
are really great books for children my
four-year-old loves them so I had the
opportunity to sit down with Brad the
other day and
and here's what it sounded like so
joining us on the line in a rare things
I like interviews Brad Meltzer Brad is
the author of a number of best-selling
thrillers as well as books that I've
recommend on the shows many times
actually the I M George Washington I am
Abraham Lincoln children's series all
about historical American figures he has
a new book coming out its first new
thriller in years and it's called the
escape artist Brad thanks so much for
joining us appreciate it thank you my
friend so Brad what exactly is the
escape artist about yeah you know the
escape artist opens with NOLA Brown one
of my favorite characters I've created
years and Nola's dead government says
she's dead she's a staff sergeant who
died in a military accident a plane
crash but at Dover Air Force Base when
our hero Zig is laying the body to rest
he opens it up and sees that there's a
hidden note inside her stomach and the
note says NOLA you were right keep
running and he realizes Nola's not dead
she's alive she's on the run and she's
the escape artist and for me that's the
fictional plot that's what drives the
book but what I love is that it's based
on real details so I was on a USO tour a
number of years ago entertaining our
troops and found out about Dover Air
Force Base of course knew that Dover was
where our soldiers are fallen soldiers
are laid to rest what I didn't know is
Dover is home to our absolute top
biggest cases so whether it's 9/11 and
the Pentagon flight or the Space Shuttle
going down or our top spies around the
world they go to Dover - and that means
Dover is a place that's built on secrets
and mysteries and you'd originally
apparently heard the story that there
were actual notes found in the bodies
correct so this is this is so that's
based on actually a true thing that
you'd heard yeah no I was I always take
my plot and I give it to the real person
and the people at Dover they just blew
me away I was humbled I mean I've done
research at the White House and with
Presidents Bush and it you know it's
been an amazing experience but when I
went to Dover I'd seen nothing like it
they will spend 14 hours rewiring
someone's jaw because they want them to
see their son or daughter one last time
they'll rebuilding an entire hand
because a mother specifically says I
want to hold my son's hand one more time
and so I gave these amazing people my
heroes I was like we need heroes like
this in the world I wanted to make them
the heroes of this book of the escape
artist and I gave them the plot I said
could you hide
her note in a body and they told me that
if a plane was going down this is true
that if you ate the note at the right
time and the note went down into your
stomach the liquids in your stomach
would actually protect the note and I
thought no that's a cool story and what
they said was it's not just a story it
happened on 9/11 and I said what are you
talking about they said on 9/11 this is
true one of the victims on the Pentagon
flight when they opened up their stomach
there was actually a note inside and I
said you know Ben let's be honest what's
the question right there what he gotta
ask ya what in what what snow and I mean
that's crazy what's the note right I
mean that's it we've never been closer I
was like what's the note and of course
they couldn't tell me and I respect the
privacy of it I thought it had to be
someone in the military because who else
would have the wherewithal to do such a
thing but as I look back on it I
realized that person was doing what we
all do and we all want is seeking
connection right we all want to love and
be loved and to me one of my parents
died the one good thing that happened
was I got to say goodbye and I remember
they said to me this is like the
ultimate message in a bottle and the
reason I take hope from that note is
that when you put that message out there
you're gonna be heard and that's the
plot of the book I literally all I did
was just change the fact of what was on
the note and said you know you're alive
keep running and I made it sexy for a
thriller but I always base my books on
real research well the book is the
escape artist the author is Brad Meltzer
again I highly recommend the escape
artist I also recommend all of his
children's books as my daughter does she
is actually even a bigger fan of Brad
Meltzer than I am Brad thanks so much
for joining us and thanks for taking the
time out I really appreciate it
thank you brother really appreciate it
all righty so there is a thing I like go
out and check out Brad Meltzer's a new
book again it's called the escape artist
and it is well worth the read it's
really interesting and quite a good book
okay other things that I other things
that I like today so there's a book that
is very popular in term conservative
intellectual circles but is not
well-known called the revolt of the
masses called abaya
Jose Ortega y Gasset now this is written
in 1926 I believe and it was all about
the problem of having an
undifferentiated population that is
interested in overthrowing the
established order and it was
specifically written about the rise of
Marxism it's a pretty sophisticated book
it also talks a lot about the balance
between democracy and a republic and
balance between you know elites
and and the masses and whether you
actually do need people who know what
they're talking about at the top but how
do you avoid tyranny if that's the case
so check it out revolt to the masses by
Ortega ego set okay time for a quick
thing that I hate alrighty so Eminem
found it necessary to go off on the NRA
I don't know what Eminem is trying to do
at this point I know he's trying to
escape being irrelevant and so I guess
the way he thinks he's gonna do that is
ripping into the NRA all this all these
people clutching their guns etc etcetera
etcetera I have a bit of bad news for
mister mm what is actual name is
Marshall Mathers correct yeah so yes I
have some I have some bad news for mr.
Eminem in 2001 he was sentenced to
probation for gun charges right he was
apparently he the gun was not loaded
nor was it directed at anyone but the
rapper pled guilty to a concealed
weapons count on February 14th 2001 and
also he had had all sorts of problems
with run-ins with the law including
weapons he got two years probation on
gun charges back in 2001
so well done mm yeah just just well done
it again all the virtue signaling by all
these artists who are running out of
steam and so now they're looking for the
approval of the critics in the hope that
this will boost their profile a little
bit they need to make a headline again
it's it's sort of pathetic and it
demonstrates though like when was the
last time that Beethoven when Beethoven
was alive was he like you know what I
need to make a political statement now
in order for people to like my art was
this true of Brahms as it's true of
Mozart was this true of the big band
swingers in the 1940s this is true for
any of the great jazz artists I don't
think so it's only now when pop culture
and politics have completely emerged
that we're supposed to pretend that pop
artists have something deep to say about
the nature of
politics and then we cheer for them and
then we're supposedly supposed to go by
their their crappy records if they say
something nasty about the NRA okay we'll
be back here tomorrow the news is
breaking fast and furious and we will
have all of the updates I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis lover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018